ich komme aus einem familienunternehmen
aber aus einem sehr sehr klein und mein
großvater hatte ein autohaus und
väterlicherseits und mütterlicherseits
ein schreiner betrieb gabriela jaecker
hat einen anderen weg eingeschlagen als
unternehmensberaterin ihre eigene firma
gegründet mit zehn mitarbeitern die
betriebswirtin aus dem schwarzwald hat
sich in frankfurt nieder gelassen
ihr spezialgebiet familienunternehmen
die ein geschäftsführer suchen oder die
firma verkaufen wollen verantwortung
haben und wenn ein gestandener
unternehmer mit mitte 60 das zu ihnen
sagt und unternehmen das produkte man
kennt bekommt man relativ schnell zu
spüren welche verantwortung einen da
übertragen wird etwa zwei tage pro woche
ist sie unterwegs
heute ist die beraterin nach berlin
geflogen ein neuer kunde mit einem
kleinen familienbetrieb wartet auf sie
im bundesland brandenburg steht die
firma von reinhard hempel metallstreben
für den bau auch türen und fenster
stellt der unternehmer her
der gelernte schlosser beschäftigt 30
mitarbeiter
obwohl die geschäfte gut laufen sucht er
schon seit drei jahren einen nachfolger
kinder sind da aber die sind dafür sei
einfach mal nicht schaffen
die machen was andere machen so gut aber
für seine schwalbe unternehmen wie er
sagte das ist genauso ob kinder sind
oder ob ein fremder ist wir müssen diese
eigenschaften haben
und die müsste doch wollen er will
seinen betrieb verkaufen sein lebenswerk
ihre aufgabe herausfinden wer sucht eine
sensible angelegenheit die beraterin
muss den richtigen ton treffen
alles okay alles gut aber unternehmer
ist etwas anderes
ihre erfahrung viele unternehmer wollen
dann einen nachfolger verkaufen der
ihnen ähnlich ist hier treffen für ihn
eine gewisse vorauswahl an kandidaten um
genau die punkte abzuklären die für ihn
wichtig sind wie das thema bonität und
natürlich auch mal unternehmertum dass
wir jemand wirklich dann auch bereit ist
hier ins risiko zu gehen und die
nachfolge anzutreten
gabriela jaecker hilft nicht nur beim
firmenverkauf sondern sucht auch nach
geschäftsführern fehlbesetzungen blieben
am anfang nicht aus eine erfahrung die
sie nicht mehr machen will mit ihrem
team hat die unternehmensberaterin ihr
auswahl-verfahren überarbeitet seither
müssen interessenten verschiedene tests
durchlaufen und die familie richtig
kennenlernen
dafür hat sie extra workshops entwickelt
mit einem ordner in dem passus workshop
jeder beobachter und teilnehmer bekommt
einen ausgehändigt darin enthalten sind
diese strategie aufgabe danach gibt es
noch eine fachbezogene aufgabe und im
anschluss noch einen rollenspiel die
kandidaten bekommen die sozusagen an dem
tag ex des passus workshops wo sie sich
sozusagen dann innerhalb von einer
halben stunde vorbereiten und dann
präsentieren
gehen wir gleich besprechen elmar
duffner steht das noch bevor
ebenfalls ein neuer kunde der ingenieur
möchte eine nachfolge antreten und mit
eigenem kapital einsteigen
er sucht ein unternehmen mit 200 bis 500
mitarbeitern
ich habe alle berg und talfahrten schon
mitgemacht
indem man dann eben auch manchmal erlebt
zwei schritt vor ein schritt zurück
kehrt dazu zählt dann auch das dann noch
mal vielleicht auch wehmut käuferseite
auftritt und man dann vielleicht noch
mal manche gespräche direkt von vorne
wieder startet um wieder die alte
beziehungsebene herzustellen
gabriela jaecker ist gut im geschäft
rund 15 nachfolgen versucht sie derzeit
zu regeln ihr honorar ein drittel des
jahresgehalts des zukünftigen managers